はい では始まります はい
次のセクションは生き方の整理整頓という始末の仕方に対する理論
これから仏教の話に入ります
価値の始まり 生きることが苦だからこそ
その苦を和らげることに意味があります
これから純粋に仏教の説明です
生きることは苦です ですから
この苦を和らげることに意味があるんです
苦を和らげてくれるものに価値が生じます
はい わかりやすい例 生きているとお腹が空くんです
お腹が空くことは苦しいんです
その苦しみを和らげますね
食べ物で ですから 食べ物に価値があるんです
食べ物になぜ価値があるのかというと
我々の苦しみを和らげるからなんです
だから私たちはね お腹が空いていると
お腹が空いたんだから新聞買いましょうとか買いません
価値がないんで その時は
草でも買いましょうとかね
はしません だからこの価値が生じるためには
私の苦しみを和らげるということにならなくちゃいけないんです
皆様方は情報を知らないという苦しみが生まれる
そうするとさっさと紀伊国屋みたい大きな書店に行って
ドイツ語かフランス語の新聞を買うですかね
買わない なぜ 情報が知らないで困るという苦しみが
フランス語の新聞読んでも直らないんです
だって読めないんだからね
その代わりに日本語の新聞を買う
だから皆様にとっては日本語の新聞に価値がありまして
フランス語 ドイツ語の新聞には価値がありません
なぜ 我々の苦しみを和らげてくれませんだからね
それは価値の本当の話
この社会がやっているこの付加価値とは違います
呼吸と水を 服も食べ物
服 住居 薬などに価値があるんです
あの食べ物だけ仏教はしますけど
食べ物の中に呼吸も入っていて
水も入っていて 体に入れるものは全部入ってます
で 病気になってると薬っていうことは別なものになりますね
その 4つに価値があるんですよ
いくら高くてもしょうがないんです
いくらケチな人でも病気になると
もう高いお金を払って治療するんです
しかし カタログを持たない人間の価値観が狂ってるんです
しかし カタログ持ってないでしょう
だったらもう価値観狂ってます
そういうわけで これで初めて仏教は価値観
どのように成り立つものかということを教えているんです
だから我々はもうこれから考えなくてはいけない
人生は 物に価値を入れる場合は
勝手に人がつけた価値に乗るんじゃないんです
自分に価値 価値があるのかと
ですから この店の品物を見て
あれ あれも買いたいんだけど
もう 20万円だからとか
自分に入らなかったら
あれは 1円の価値もないんです
だから いつでもデパートに行ったら
もうスーパーに行ったら
自分個人の苦しみを和らげるのでしょうかということだけで品物を選べばそこでしょうに
みんな食べてるんだから
これはとかね この間テレビで放映したんだから
どうでもいいんだよ そんなことは
苦を目指す 狂った価値観でものを得ても
苦を和らげるはずはないんです
価値観狂ったら苦は増えるんです
すごい可愛くてかっこいいんだからといって
いきなりトラを飼うんじゃないんです
まあ珍しい 珍しいですよ
トラは 豪華豪華ですよ
トラは 例えばね 皆さん
ものすごい高級車よりも馬が高いでしょ
ベンツは 2台  3台ぐらい買えますね
クマ一頭の馬一頭の値段で
だから馬買う 関係ないでしょうに
まあ北海道に住んでるとかね
そういう系列の人なら買うのはいいんだけど
普通皆様サラリーマンの方々にはもういらん
もう苦しみは増えるだけね
買ったならば減らないんです
だから物に価値を入れる場合は自分で入れてください
会社に任すんじゃないんです
健康のために麻薬を普及するようなことをですね
我々やっているのは 現代の生き方は狂った価値観の代表です
釈尊が価値観がおかしいと叱責したのは
それほど価値観が狂った人々のことではなかったんです
これで私も困ってますけど
お釈迦様があなたの価値観狂ってるんだよと怒鳴られたのは
我々に対してじゃなくて
ごく質素に生活している人々のことなんです
家族を養いたいとかね
なんとか食べ物を得たいとかね
奥さんにちょっと外へ出られないんだから
服を1着買いたいとか
その程度の価値観を持ってる人々に叱責したんです
価値観狂ってるんだよと
だからお釈迦様は現代時代で払われたらどう言えばいいんでしょうかね
これほど価値観狂ってるんだから
だって我々から見てもね
家族に美味しいものを食べさせたいっていうことは
狂った価値観じゃないでしょうね
子供にももうちょっと元気で遊んで
いいものを食べて早く大きくなってほしいという期待ぐらいは狂ってないんですよ
しかし それについてお釈迦様は気をつけろよと
危ないんだよと 狂いますよと言ったんだから
現代社会にしたら お釈迦様にも言葉なくなる可能性あります
それぐらい我々は価値観狂ってるんです
次に 楽しみとは何ですかと
人は生きることが楽しいと思う
苦であるのにね 楽しくはないんだけど
人はそう思うんですね
では その楽しみとは何でしょうか？と
生きることは苦に決まってますけど
なのに我々は楽しいと思うんですね
それで私たちとは楽しいと思うのは何なのかと
5つですよ これは五欲とパンチャカーマと言うんですね
5つの五欲対象パンチャカーマグナ
喜びを与える 好ましい喜び
また長い文章ありましたけども
省略しました 喜びを与える好ましい色
声 香り 味 触 触れることですね
5つです それで楽しいんです
例えば 綺麗なものを見ると楽しい
綺麗な声を聞くと楽しい
それから綺麗な声を聞きたい
私の声ではなくて で 綺麗な香りを嗅ぎたい
美味しい味を味わいたいと
そういう時は生まれる感覚に人が楽しいと言うんです
だからそれは人生は楽しいって見て誤解です
人生は楽しいじゃなくて
五欲の対象に触れることが楽しみを生まれて
そういうふうな科学的な定義使わなきゃよくないという
楽しみを感じることが五欲対象への長所ですね
見えるもの 聞こえるもの
味わえるもの 嗅げるものでの長所は楽しいこと
まあ宝石とかね もうああいうアクセサリーとかね
何の役にも立たんだけど
まあ見ると美しいんですね
見るときれい あ かわいいと思っちゃうんです
だからそのわずかな楽しみなんですよ
すごい金取るのは ん 間違ったっけ
うん はい 次 五欲対象の短所
長所だけでは馬鹿になりますから
短所も見てくださいと
釈尊の言葉をそのまま紹介します
人は会計 農業 商売 家畜業
公務員などの職業をする
もっと職業たくさんありましたけど
日本語の単語を知らなくても省略しました
で 虫かヘビ 太陽 風などで苦しむ
仕事をする時はね まあ虫に噛まれるんだからやめるということはできるんでしょう
田んぼの仕事をすると
今日はもう太陽がきついんだからやめるとかね
こんな話はできませんだからね
喉が渇いても お腹が空いても我慢することになる
仕事の時は仕事自体は決して楽ではありません
これは欲の短所 だから五欲を得るために仕事をするんだけど
仕事でどんなひどいに遭うかわからないんですよ
仕事自体苦しい 期待次
期待した収入が得られなかったら
まあ悩んだり泣いたり苦しんだりするんですよ
途方に暮れちゃうんですね
せっかく苦労して田んぼを作ったのに
水に流されたら 大変ショックですよ
今の日本の社会そうでしょう
金融危機でものすごいショックで
特にリストラになっている人々の精神的苦しみをちょっと考えてみてください
どれほど大変なことかと
もうやっとあの寮で 1ヶ月間はいられるようにと
その間で仕事探しなさいと
もうトヨタ会社にクビにされた人はどこで仕事を探すんですかね
そういうことだからね
だからもうこの収入が得られなくなると
並大抵の苦しみじゃないんです
もしも期待通りに財産が生まれたら
それを守ることに苦労する
じゃあ財産入ったとしましょう
まあちょっとした給料じゃなくて
結構財産が入ったとしましょう
それからこれ守らなくていけないんですね
王というのは政府ですね
王に泥棒に取られないように
火 風 水で被害を受けないように
嫌な人に取られないようにと苦労するんです
自分の財産を それでも王に取られたり
また盗まれた盗まれたり
被害に災害に当てた当たったりする
それで悩んだり苦しんだり
泣いたりすることになる
また途方に暮れることになる
いくら守っても持っていかれる場合があります
泥棒に持っていかれたってのはあんまり悔しくないんだけど
この嫌な人が家に来てね
持っていくと一番もうしゃくに障るでしょ
まあ自分の同じ仲間で知ってる人なんですけど
あの人だけにはとかね
時々ね 姑さんがね もうお嫁さんにこの財産を取られるのはもう大嫌いとかね
思ったりしたりする場合ありますよ
しかし 取られますよ それから
財産のために王と王は王と
商人は商人と 知識人は知識人と
父は息子と 兄弟は兄弟と
友人は友人と戦ったり
喧嘩したり 殴り合い殴り合いをやったり
武器を持って攻撃をしたりします
今の世界でもそういうことなんですよ
兄弟も時々財産のために恐ろしい喧嘩することがあるんです
それで苦しむ 怪我をする
死ぬことにもなる 財産のために
それから欲のために鎧をかぶり
剣をと弓を持って戦争に挑む
火の矢が降ってる間に
刀が交わしている間に
湧いてる油をかけてる間に飛び込む
昔の戦争のやり方ですよ
昔は結構怖かったんです
今は隠れて殺すんだからね
戦争に行ったらもう敵軍がね
あの矢に火をつけて もう雨のごとく撃ってるんですよ
それでも前に進まなくちゃいけないんです
それから油やいろんなものをぐっとぐっと煮出したドコッとかけたりするんです
それでも進まなくちゃいけない
欲のため それで死に至る怪我をしたり
また死んでしまったりもする
これも欲の短所ですね
また 欲のために欲の原因で強盗したり
家を破ったり 暴力団を築いたり
殺人を起こしたりする
彼らを王の使用人に取られて
足を切断させたり 手を切断させたり
首を切られたり 象に踏まされたり
踏ませたり 油の釜で煮たりする
昔の罰ですね もう釜に油を入れて
これをもう火をかけて人をボーンと放り投げるんです
犯罪者を それも欲があるから起こる苦しみです
また 人は欲のために欲の原因で体で悪行為をする
罪を犯す 言葉で思考で悪行為をする
罪を犯す 彼らが死後 不幸に地獄に陥る
これも欲の短所なのです
で 生きるためにはいろんなものが必要ですけど
この楽しみという あれ
ちょっと余計なんですけどね
それに行っちゃうとこんな目に遭いますよと
だからこの状況 私はわざとこの経典そのまま紹介して
なんか古い感じさせましたけど
現代も同じこと全く変わってない
どれほど戦争起きてますか？どれほど人死んでますかね
で まあ一つ思い出す例っていうのは
アメリカがいろんな国に戦争を売ったりするでしょうに
だからもうその時は弾として劣化ウラン使ったりする
いくらでもあるんだから
安いし 大量に作れるし
これは大丈夫や大丈夫
大丈夫じゃないんですよ
ただ認めない 放射被害被爆するんだと
政府は法律的に認めない
それで十分だそうです
いくら放射能を浴びても
政府は認めませんだからね
それでイラクでも放射能ですごい子供たちが病気になったり
がんになったりとかあったりしたみたいですし
戦争終わって帰る兵士さんもアメリカ人でかなりそういうことで苦労して病気になったりしますけど
政府は認めないんですね
だからお金くれないんです
だからただ金のために
欲のためにそこまでやるんですよ
で で 価値の狂い 自分に楽しみ喜びを与えるから
物に価値があるとする
喜びも具体的でなくなる
観念的なものも喜びにする
で 物に価値があるのは
例えば食べ物に価値があるのは
お腹が空いた苦しみが消してくれるだからなんです
それでもあまり食べたくはないんですよ
人間が だから味も欲しいんですね
そうすると味に釣られて必要なものを食べたりする
いくら体に必要な栄養分やと思っていっても
まずいんだったらもう結構ですと
もう食べないことにする
人間認めてないんだけど
食べることも苦ですよ
だから我々は私たちを騙すんですよ
これ美味しいんだから
いくらなんでも食べなきゃ
ということで で 形を美しく作るんですよ
料理の あまりにも綺麗な形だから食べちゃうんです
そうすると味がまずいんだけど
気づかないんです あの京都のお菓子みたいにね
すっごい綺麗でしょ あれまずいんですけどね
でも世界一美しいんです
作品です 芸術作品です
味のにおいては えーと
天ぷらを見て欲が生じるのは具体的です
それは狂ったとは言いませんよ
いくらダイエットの女の子であっても
美味しいケーキ見ちゃうとすぐすぐ手が出ちゃうんですね
あれは頭 あんた頭狂ってるんだってはないんだよ
あれは具体的ですよ 時間が経ったら
経ったものなら欲が消えますよ
だって天ぷら見て なんて美味しいんでしょうかと欲が出たんだけど
もうちょっと食べられなくなっちゃう
あっちこちやっていろんなことやっていて
また見るともう時間が経っちゃったりして
なんかグニャっとしたりしてね
もう食べたくはないんですね
だからその具体的な欲っていうのは
まあ消えちゃうんですよ
しかし 野球選手のサイン入りのキャップをもらって最高に幸せっていうのは何ですかね
あれは あの欲がいつ消えますかね
野球選手が帽子にサイン入れて
はい どうぞと まあ宝くじ当たったぐらい喜んだりして
あの欲が具体的ですか？と
あの欲がいつ消えますかね
天ぷら食いたかった欲がすぐ消えますけどね
だから具体的な欲と この観念的な欲って 2つあるんです
危ないのは観念的な欲なんですよ
具体的な欲じゃないんです
だから捨てられない もう観念のせいで捨てられないんですよ
物事を 60年前の新婚旅行の 1枚の写真とか
今の主人から最初にもらったかんざしのプレゼント
かんざしは今使いませんだけどね
大事に置いておくんです
また 家代々守ってきたものなどもたくさんありますね
当然価値があると思っているんです
その当然価値があるんですよ
どこにあるのかというと
この観念の世界なんです
60年前にとってボロマイでというのは
もうカビももう生えたりしてね
見たものじゃないし 若者
孫たち ひ孫たちはなんだこれやとかね
思うものなんですよ しかし
おばあさまにとってはすごい価値があるんですよ
歴史的な価値がある 文化財として認定される建物
仏像などもあるでしょう
皆様 すごく大事にしているでしょ
でも時々火事になるんですよ
なんのことか あっと困ったものが灰になりますよ
どれほど日本の寺はね
もうどんな寺に見ても
これはもう3回目作ったものとかね
火事になって全部焼けられたとかね
やっとこの仏像 この観音像だけ持って逃げまったとかね
そんな話ばっかりだから
文化財と言ったっても
結局はその様なんですよ
もらった調弦 お歳暮 引き出物なども具体性がないが
妄想でつけた価値があるんです
お引き出物やらね お歳暮とか
あれ全く使わないでしょう
よく食べ物いろいろある
あれ食べる気にならないね
あのいろんな美しい缶に染めた
もう瓶に漬けたものとか
なんか見る限り高そうな感じがしますけどね
食べる気にはならない
そのまま置いておくんですね
感情が思い出がつける価値があるんですね
そういうものには 自分が使わないが高いものという
これは作った単語です
辞書にないんです だから発音がそれから考えなくちゃいけないんです
で まあ金の悪魔がね つけた価値があるんですね
これは高いものだよと
もしかすると必要になるかも
高く売れるかもという願望的な価値もあります
そうなってくると 物は捨てられなくなります
それで正しい価値観から順番で考えていくと
我々はどれほど狂っているのかと
ですから あなたはといった人間
誰でも人間っていうのはあまりかっこよくない
ただのゴミ捨て場なんです
自分自身がゴミ捨て場なんだから
ゴミが自分のところに捨てる捨てるって自分がいただいているだけで取っているだけ
立派な人間ですね 動くゴミ捨て場という
使用しない 喜びを与えないものはゴミです
しかし 絶えず集める 溜まる
我々は巨大なゴミの山を支える土台になっているんです
ゴミに潰されるのは構わないが
もう一つ問題があります
それで人々はゴミに潰されて死んでしまいますよ
それは一向に構いません
もう一つ問題がありますよ
一個一個の品物は心を汚すんです
そこは問題です  60年前の写真 1枚置いておくと
その分心が汚れるんです
サイン入りの帽子とかバットとかもらったら
その分すごく心が汚れるんです
ゴミで心が汚れるんです
自分がゴミのゴミの捨て場なんですね
だからゴミ捨て場は当然汚染します
それで我々の心がひどく汚れているんです
そのゴミのせいで ゴミがたまるということは
煩悩がたまるという相互依存の相互関係
初めからも無知なので
必要の理解 必要の理解はありません
前説明した必要というポイント
それはない 煩悩だからものを必要とする
煩悩だからもの だって
だって生きていきたい
死にたくないってことも生存欲でしょ
これでものを取らなきゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
だからまず煩悩だからものを取るはめになる
ものを取ると煩悩が増える
煩悩が増えると さらにものを取る
さらに さらに煩悩が増えるという
得たものによって 新たに執着や怒りの煩悩が溜まる
煩悩が増えるとさらに必要になる
この世であの世で幸福が一切破壊になるまで貯めて貯めていくんです
この世でも頓服不幸になって破滅になるまで物を貯めるんです
この世で終わらない心が汚れたんだから
あの世でも破滅になるんです
そういうことで 素晴らしい悪循環ですよ
この我々の狂った価値観が
そういうことで 物の整理ということにいかなくちゃいけないんですね
使うもの 必要なものを確認する
これシンプルですよ 家のゴミをね
これは使っている これは必要という風にもラベル貼っちゃえば
捨てなくていいんで たまに楽しいんですよ
ラベル貼って貼って貼ってみてください
絶対捨てないと決めてね
そうするとやりやすいんです
絶対処分しない しかし
言われたんだからラベルだけ貼っておくと
使うもの 使わないもの
いらないものとかね 十年一回使ったものとかね
ラベル貼ってみると ものすごく面白くなるんです
人生は 使わないもの 不必要なものは苦しみを与させる
自分が呼び寄せた災難です
それで家の品物にラベルを貼ってみたら
まあ使うものはありますよ
鍋とかね 電子レンジとかね
冷蔵庫とかね はありますよ
そこで台所の上にちょっと開けてみたら
もう半分以上使わないもの
私のも同じことですけどね
私はそれを知っています
私は使うのはこれとこれとこれだけだと
で 他のものが 私は初めからもういらないゴミだと決めているんだから
全然災難になりませんだけど
時々誰かによってもう壊れたりしますよ
なんか誰か男の子が遊びに来たってね
まあじゃあなんとかします
なんとかいったところで
合わせていろいろ壊しちゃったんですね
私は本心 すごく喜んじゃう
よかったなと これで捨てられるぞと
本人がすごくびっくりして
すいません ごめんなさい
これ壊れたんですけど
一つ買ってくるんで この野郎
黙っていろと こちら喜んでいるのにね
壊れたことに そういうことで使わない
必要でないとラベルを貼った品物
すべて災難の原因なんですよ
だから この火事になる時も
そういうもののせいで火事になるんですよ
早いうちに自分はそのものから離れる
ものから離れることで
得ることよりも心が ものから離れることで
得ることよりも心がリラックスしますよ
得ることというのは 儲かった
儲かったで喜んじゃうでしょ
それよりは離れた方 離れた時の快感はすごいんです
本当はみんな経験ないだけで
物を捨てる時の快感 爽快感というのはすごいんです
で 物を溜まるとあんまり快感ないんですよ
安らぎを感じる この事実を発見します
それもこれから経験して発見してほしいんです
身軽いことは心が軽いことです
身軽いとは心が軽いです
煩悩の重さがないんです
それから 出家の規則からヒントを得られますね
出家は死句 飲食 住薬は不可欠な基本的な働き
必要性を日々観察しなすことはならないんですね
出家する人々は この衣食住薬に対しては
毎日この目的で使いますよと
いわゆる使わなかったら死ぬ
食べ物食べなかったら死ぬ
だから 死を乗り越えるために食べると
生きるために なんで生きるのかというと
やっぱり修行しなくちゃと
修行して解脱に達するためにまでは生きていなきゃできないんだからね
そういうことで 強引に生きることに意味をつけて
ちょっと食べると 命をつなぐために
それ一寸でも観察しなくちゃいけないんですよ
そうでないとすぐ あの
何て言いますか 価値観が狂っちゃうんです
出家でもかなり狂ってますよ
価値観が というのは ほとんどみんな狂ってます
たまたまではないんです
で 体を隠せる程度の服で満足するべきです
それより優れたものをいただいたら
それは特別に恵まれたことにする
特例にする そんな感じで
服の場合はちょっと体
寒さに暑さでちょっと守ってもらえばそれで十分だと
でもそれなりにいいものをもらったら
これは特例ですと と観察しなさいよと
これは戒律の一部なんです
戒律です 家具などの大きな品物
不動産などは個人の持ち物にはならない
だから出家しても 家具なんかはもらっても自分のものにならないんです
例えば 信者さんがこの家具をはい
どうぞお布施しますと
はいはい どうぞありがとうございますと言うんだけど
法律的には仏教の法律的には自分のものにならないんです
自分が私が受けても 受けたものはその瞬間からサンガのものなんです
そういうふうにお釈迦様はすごい決めているんです
それは共通財産になるするんです
自分が必要な時 借用する
これ 結構気分がいいんですよ
これ 俺の豪華な椅子やではなくて
ちょっと借用すると 借用するときは自分のものを使うよりは気分がいいんです
面白いんです その原理も
在家はそのようにはいきませんね
余計に苦しむと 物に奴隷にされることを避けます
避けられます だから我々に出家に教えたことは
皆様には真にできませんし
これは不可能です 皆様にはいろんな品物が必要でしょうし
もう自分の不動産が人のものにしちゃ困るでしょうにね
だからまあ人はそれ守ってくれませんしね
だから在家にはそこまでは無理ですけど
ちょっとヒントを得られる
このヒントは あまりにも物に依存すると物の奴隷になる
物の奴隷にならない程度で気をつければよろしいのです
余計に物を溜めることで
誰かが物がなくて困ることになるのです
罪になります それで我々は価値観が狂ってるんだから
溜めるは溜めるは溜めるは溜めるは
狂暴な人はたくさん金やら財産やら土地やら建物やら
何でも貯めちゃう ありったけの株証券買って貯めたりするんですね
そうすると他の人々に収入を得る道が閉ざすんです
他の人々に食べる方法を閉ざしているんです
地球は平等で みんなの財産なんです
どこに生まれたっても
地球で生まれたんだからね
それがいろんな人々は大量に独り占めにするんですね
それは本当は他人の生きる権利を奪ったことです
だから罪です 軽々く儲かってもね
はい そういうことで捨てることを覚えてください
私ははっきり捨てなさいとは言ってないんです
ちゃんと理論で どのような生き方って中道ですから
仏教はね 家の財産 品物の半分捨てなさいとかね
コーランではね まあ一年一回
一割か二割ですね 財産のもう貧しい人にあげなさいと
そういう風な この非論理的な話はしません
仏教は中道でよく考えてくださいと
はい 捨てなさいという話になると
物がなければいい 貧困でいいと思って
問題を物のせいにするのは邪見です
金のせいで苦しんでるんだから金がなければいい
私は美味しいものを食べたいんだから
グルメのせいで心は汚れたんだから
これから食べないことにするぞという
これちょっと邪見です
勘違いです 苦行も断食も邪見です
だから今日から断食するぞと
邪見です そんなのは ものを処分しても
そのものに対する執着があれば捨ててないんです
例えば 美味しいものを食いたくて食いたくて欲がいっぱいある人が
やっぱりこれで苦しみますから
じゃあ断食します 言ったっても食いたい気持ちはそのままでしょう
特に断食に行くでしょ
日本のいろいろ道場ありますからね
この断食道場に行く人々に限って
食欲はあまりにもありすぎ
帰ったら必ず爆発します
1週間ぐらい苦労して
そういう場合は仏教は修行だとは認めないんですね
それから時々あげてから他人の使い方に文句を言ったりする場合ありますね
人にものをあげてから
なんだこのお粗末な使い方とか
私の大事なものでしょうと
もうあげてない 本当は
まだまだ愛着 執着心にあるんです
いまだに精神的に自分のものです
だからその場合は だからそれは間違った使い方
形だけ はいはい 持っていってくださいと言ったっても
欲しいなとかね だから監視するんです
どう使うのかとかね 心の中が清浄でなければ
形だけの顔の衣 皮の衣をまとったり
髪の髪を結んでおいたりなどなどをしても無意味だと
ある一人いたんです その人が自分の髪の毛をね
もう結んで上にターバンにして洗わないんです
だからすごい汚いんです
それで服は代わりに皮一枚で着て
体だらけ 泥だらけでもう苦労しながらいるんです
お釈迦様を見たらね お前何やってるのかと
心の中は汚れだらけでしょうと
外だけ磨いてるんだと
意味がないんだと 心を清らかにする道を歩まない人は
他人の家で托鉢 托鉢はビッカって言うんですね
するだけでは比丘出家にはなりませんと
あの 比丘っていうのは托鉢するものって意味なんです
比丘って 出家っていうのは
で だからって家から家托鉢に出たんだからといって比丘じゃないんだよと
比丘は誰かというと 悪も善も超えて
この世の何も何にもとらわれない人が比丘であると
だから悪もないし 善もないし
何にもとらわれ 一切価値観を捨てていて
完全たる清らかな平安な心を作っている人が托鉢しようがしなかろうが関係なく比丘ですと
で ダンマパダに教えられてます
うん